wie kam es dazu dass du nach den
parodien angefangen hast jetzt rapper zu
werden also als opa durchzustarten
sie kam es oft idee ich habe mit dem
berlin angefangen und habe einen
gewissen halt bekommen paar leute kennen
mich jetzt und ich wollte immer schon
meine rap künste zeigen
und jetzt kann ich das jetzt setzt sich
ein video online und sehen wie leute und
die leute können darüber urteilen und
das feedback ist gut
cazorla denn fragt wer wofür stehen die
zwei und die sieben in deinem namen halo
fans legen die 27 steht für mein viertel
wo ich aufgewachsen bin wo ich geboren
bin roderbruch in hannover
die postleitzahl ist 30 6 27
die letzten zwei zahlen schöne grüße
ultra das land möchte wissen wales 7 was
hat dich dazu motiviert zu rappen und
was inspiriert dich gruß sah nd sarin
hallo was hat mich dazu inspiriert
ich habe viel rap gehört ich höre es
immer noch und damals haben meine großen
brüder anfangen zu brennen angefangen zu
retten und ja ich habe es ausprobiert
und jetzt zehn jahre hat die frage
bleibt es auch bei den gebrüdern oder
machst du dein eigenes ding
ich bleib noch bei den hobby brüdern
dass meine brüder
ich kann nicht weg aber macht nebenbei
noch mein eigenes ding
mendes 0 1 weil was denkst du über
deutsch rap und was kann man besser
machen
man kann nichts besser machen alles ist
super jeder hat seinen eigenen style
jeder alles läuft jeder wissen es wird
ist das ist rap
was man besser machen kann ist
eigentlich nichts außer ein neuer rapper
kommt dazu wie ich und das tue ich
gerade adrian black fragt wer mich würde
es war gern interessieren wir sehr fair
trade zrt kennengelernt habt wie eure
freundschaft entstanden ist und ob er
noch zukünftig zusammen eigener musik
macht so schön hieß es erstmal
wir haben ihn kennengelernt damals in
der schule in der realschule
er konnte damals sehr gut singen und
damals schon videos gedreht dann haben
wir um aufgenommen zu unserer gruppe das
war vor 16 jahren und ja wir uns kennen
lernt und auf jeden fall werden die
zusammen musik machen erst sechsmal oder
so auf mein album vertreten
und ja da wird etwas kommen 91
interessiert joel 7 gab es schon mal
ärger von irgendeinem rapper der war es
gegen eure parodien hatte ja das gab es
auf jeden fall aber es hat sich schnell
wieder geklärt
deswegen ist okay wir keine namen
aufzuzählen
frankie 700 wenn es einen gäbe mit dem
die rollen tauschen könntest welcher
wäre dieser rapper und warum ich möchte
mit werken wie gefällt dass ich möchte
mit niemandem rollen tauschen dann habe
ich weiß ich wie gelähmt
sie leben meistens allem drogen und das
möchte xxxx möchte wissen wie hast du
beziehungsweise die ganze bibi brüder
coen steigenden hype wahrgenommen
habt ihr ihn überhaupt wahrgenommen es
war eine überraschung also wie sie xxxx
xxxx also handel so hunter xxxx xxxx
schöne grüsse emma ja es war auf jeden
fall eine überraschung bei uns der hype
wir haben uns natürlich gefreut jeder
andere sich auch freuen würde
wir haben ihn wahrgenommen und jetzt
versuchen wir das beste daraus zu machen
alle tiere sind wie immer frisch für die
feuerwehr
ich bin aber ganz häufig dosen von tipps
von waste renditen ihre fragen an
briefkästen lisa die tiere kaum vom gang
zum in den jörg das freut den titel wie
auch immer danke erst mal dass der meine
dass sie das gefällt was ich mache wie
bin ich auf den titel bekommen
ich war damals ein schlimmer junge ein
gangster und jetzt studiere ist gerade
maschinenbau informatik und werde bald
ingenieur sein
deswegen habe ich mein album von
gangster zum ingenieur glanz und kaufte
ihm ein halber meter
ich brauche deine unterstützung auf
jeden fall